Up to this point you've learned a lot about the basics of data visualization.
You learn what constitutes good data visualization from and you learned what
types of visual and coding choices you can make to represent your data.
>> You've seen where data visualization fits into the larger process of
data science.
And you have also been introduced to some of the technologies that
data scientists and data artists choose when they're creating graphics and
visualizations of their own.
We've had a chance to play with D3 in the browser and
work with some code so hopefully I have what your appetite for
the types of visualizations we'll be creating in this course.
>> Next we're going to be going over some more design centric elements of
data visualization and also how to choose the right type of visualization for
your data type.
We'll also arm you with a few tools to think critically about the data
visualizations that you create and
also analyze data visualizations that you see in the wild